large controversial opinionated
disputatious quo to ism's defender of
the aesthetic and cognitive standards in
the profession maintainer of canonical
standards for the study in appreciation
of lid or literature original inimitable
intractable the King Kong of criticism
full of Zumba hardly the mildest of men
as he claims to be Harold Bloom has
dominated literary criticism for our
time there is no one like him as one
critic says bloom bloom he takes up the
room he's known all the world from Maine
to Khartoum I'll end with a line and a
half from Shakespeare as seems
appropriate
why man he doth bestride the narrow
world like a colossus please join me in
welcoming as a commenting leading
lecture in Shakespeare at Yale Harold
Bloom
Henryk kinda remarked that there is a
God and His name is Aristophanes I
revised that too there is no god but God
and his name is William Shakespeare
Samuel Johnson told us that the essence
of poetry is invention following that
sublime critic I called an endless book
I'm sorry about Shakespeare the
invention of the human fourteen years
later I'm still chided for confusing the
board of Thomas Alva Edison following
Johnson my trope suggested that
Shakespeare the essential poetic
dramatist had revealed to us much that
always had been there but had not been
available before he discerned it his
recognition of the human was an act of
literary knowledge a mode concerning
which we still comprehend rather little
Falstaff Hamlet and Cleopatra or
transactions in knowledge so are you and
I the ancient Greek word for word logos
in his root means a gathering together
the Hebrew devar for word a word that is
also an act and a thing derives from a
root meaning to thrust forward something
that previously was held well back in
the self when I listened to Falstaff or
to Hamlet
I hear that bringing forward what we
learned from Shakespeare's most vital
men and women is the knowledge they
incarnate this is not the knowledge of
the philosophers or of the Mystics or
even the knowledge of Homer or Dante it
is unique to Shakespeare though
Montaigne and Cervantes his greatest
contemporaries are closer to it than
anyone else before or since the
self-awareness of Falstaff Hamlet Iago
and Cleopatra is the salient quality
that renders them endless to meditation
ours and their own if their vitalism is
illusory why then so is yours and mine
for we are their descendants much of our
self-consciousness had its inception in
their self-awareness what we cannot
catch up to is the amazing
khempo of their words thoughts acts that
preternatural quickness emanates from
their playfulness ludic intensity
renders the purposes of playing
purposeless confronting us with mimetic
energies we scarcely apprehend let alone
absorb reread the tragedy of Hamlet
Prince of Denmark and Center upon the
thousand lines from act 2 scene 2
through act 3 scene 2 a quarter of the
play in this uncut composite length what
you confront in that whirligigs wanders
only rarely is it the imitation of an
action or any other aspect of theatrical
illusion plays within plays soliloquies
theatrical gossip lectures on acting
crowd upon you until you do begin to
feel that Hamlet somehow is an actual
person intruding into a dress rehearsal
for an unwritten drama that scarcely
could be shaved sage really even if it
were achieved Pirandello Brecht Samuel
Beckett whoever you will could not match
this kaleidoscope of a theatre of mine
so capacious we still cannot and compel
sit
Hamlet palpably is an experimental
thinker rather more than here
Shakespeare's thought experiment his
seven soliloquies break the process of
the discursive in ways that prompted
Nietzsche's up of them that for which we
can find words is something already dead
in our hearts there's always a kind of
contempt in the act of speaking I can
think of nothing more alien to the
Magnificent Sir John Falstaff who excels
even Prince Hamlet and starting fresh
meanings rather than repeating old ones
Falstaff finds avalanches of words for
what lives fiercely in his heart and
always he glorious in the act of
speaking few others and all of
imaginative literature speak so superbly
although has damnable iteration that are
indeed able to corrupt the Saint thou
has done much harm upon me how God
forgive me for it before I knew thee how
I knew nothing and now am i if a man
should speak truly little better than
one of the wicked I must give over this
life and I will give it over by the Lord
and I do not I am I
I'll be damned for never Kingston and
Christendom
before I knew thee I knew nothing
addressed by the fat Knight to the
prince is unanswerable and sublimely
outrageous sometimes I'm use that the
two oldest persons in Shakespeare a Lear
and Falstaff who have in common only
their age which at 81 I sheer happily
resembling in temperament Falstaff and
not the tragic monarch knowing Falstaff
is more than entertainment though
precisely that with Shakespeare's first
grand triumph with his audience
Hotspur says a Falstaff and his
irregular humerus that they daft the
world aside and bid it pass you know
actually my dears I'm going to transfer
myself at this point to the table
Hotspur says Oh Falstaff and his
irregular humerus that they Daffy the
world decide that is a bitter decide we
too should thrust the moldy fix collars
aside and let them pass so as properly
the apprehend surgeon and learned to
know what he knows which is what he is
his absolute sense of being false F is
the Socrates of each chief and he
teaches us to be in the difficulty of
what it is to be his best student the
ungrateful Prince how absorbs the lesson
and intends to hang the instructor or in
any case see him cut down upon the field
of battle as life itself principle as
well as particle or staff declines to be
slain he will waste away and he will die
of a broken heart
but that scarcely diminishes his
ontological self he teaches all things
in himself with exuberance defiance of
time but above everything else the sheer
joy of being of being a human being more
even then Chaucer's the Wife of Bath the
wonderful panner of Rabelais Sancho
Panza he manifests the blessing the
great Hebrew blessing which I've always
translated as more life long ago I
wearied of being told that Hamlet and
Falstaff are men made out of
in more than 80 years of countless
friendships and allows enmities I've
encountered no one among us half so real
or so intelligent as the prince and Sir
John if to be a Shakespeare scholar
entails denying or evading his creation
of character and of human personality
that I'm pleased to be merely a reader
literary knowledge is not a shadow of
our failure to know one another but the
larger form of what that relation yet
might be darker strains reverberate when
we realize we are uncertain our
self-knowledge equals that of Falstaff
and of Hamlet which can cause distress
since their catastrophes come precisely
from their greatest human gifts years
ago in London I lunched a number of
times with Owen Barfield a wonderful
profound student of poetic thought I
remember our final meeting when Owen
asked me Harold does it not cause you
chagrin when you reflect that your
emotions originally with Shakespeare's
thoughts pondering this I replied we had
become his characters reflection also of
course Ralph Waldo Emerson's when he
observed that Shakespeare had composed
the text of modern life Wittgenstein
strongly dissented he I realized that
Shakespeare was too English and much
more creator of language than of thought
or of character David Hume would have
agreed with Wittgenstein but I prefer
Hegel with his very fine perception that
Falstaff and Hamlet Iago and Cleopatra
are free artists of themselves
Shakespeare and those of them with the
capacity to recreate their souls each of
them his or her own Demiurge the
fiercest of demiurges this once would
have been the house in which to utter
the great name yahwah who if Jesus and
Hamlet makes up a triad of the West's
major literary characters inaugurates
the particular metaphor of being that
Shakespeare Evie
and subverts in his most vitalizing
characters in Exodus 3 yahwah calls his
reluctant prophet moses so as a sin that
slow of speech shepherd the hebrew is
obscure it could mean either that moses
stutters or that he stammers i suspect
his ass Tamra so as to send that slow of
speech Shepherd down to Egypt to lead
the supposedly chosen people back to
Canon extraordinary text which I quote
from King James and Moses said unto God
behold when I come unto the children of
Israel and shall say unto them the god
of your father's has sent me unto you
and they shall say to me what is his
name what shall I say unto them and God
said unto Moses I am that I am and he
said thus shalt thou say unto the
children of Israel I am have sent me
unto you the Geneva Bible inaugurated
this interesting mistake of I am that I
am the great Protestant martyr William
Tyndale the greatest of the English
Bible Translators was much closer to the
Hebrew a Yasha area in having yahwah say
I will be what I will be as I read the
Hebrew it means I bring into being what
I bring into being punning outrageously
on his own permanently mysterious name
Yahweh States the myth of presence I
will be present whenever and wherever I
choose to be present which of course
implies he will be absent whenever he
chooses to be
I recall saying in some book or other of
yahwah I don't like him I don't trust
him I wish he would go away but he won't
Shakespeare's own dialectic is a wholly
secularized shuttle what I suppose you
might call the real presence and the
real absence teaching Shakespeare you
teach presence a teaching that enacts a
reading of his ellipses that is to say
no other writer has been anywhere near
so skilled of the art of leaving things
out so everything in the tragical
history of Hamlet Prince of Denmark is
questioned and questionable as we will
see the darker enigmas are unmentioned
and I always wonder why Shakespeare
scholars don't attend to these things
when did the erotic relationship between
Claudius and Gertrude begin who is
Hamlet's phallic father the warrior king
were his shuffling brother more than any
other Shakespearean protagonist Hamlet
does not mean what he says or say what
he means if we suspect that Claudius may
be his father can Hamlet more
intelligent than we are suspect less why
does he return from this either Elsinore
where every first thought must be his
impending death in a Drama uniquely and
openly aware of its audience we are
compelled to complicity with Hamlet who
pragmatically is an agent of death
unlike Falstaff always to be sublimely
praised because Falstaff is life's
ambassador to us Hamlet speaks 1,500
lines of what in composite editions is a
play of 4,000 lines much Shakespeare's
longest when all on stage Hamlet's
absence is a presence as there can be no
other focus the drama is his passion and
his mystery as the Gospel of Mark was
that of Jesus except that Hamlet is
unfollowed as James Joyce first
suggested a play that takes us it's
burden the meaning of self-consciousness
may hint that inner freedom can be
attained only when the protagonist can
separate his genius for expanding
consciousness from his own dangerous
passion for sheer theatricality
falstaff apotheosis of self presence
enhances his freedom by playing out the
play both Hamlet and Falstaff are great
improvisers if finally I go with
Falstaff it is because he goes into
bottle with a bottle of sherry and his
holster for swearing a mere pistol
dodging the bottle when the outraged
Prince hell throws on him the sublime
Falstaff states a zest full truth I like
not such grinning honor as Sir Walter
hath give me life which if I can save so
if not honor come son look for and
there's an end I've heard Shakespeare
scholar say to me face to face that they
actually prefer hot Spurs doomsday is
near die all die merrily and yet Hotspur
delights us because high-spirited Lee he
loves his life on his own terms
Hamlet has no love for life no love for
himself no love indeed for anyone else
be it a failure or a ratio as for the
absurd pseudo Freudian readings of the
play when the dying
Gertrude cries out oh my dear Hamlet his
response will be wretched Queen I do we
do not receive full staffs dying words
and mistress quickly wonderful cockney
prose elegy for him in Henry the fifth
but she vividly presents the scene the
Great vitalist is a little child again
playing with flowers smiling at his
fingertips and singing the 23rd psalm
pure presence hardly could be more
enhanced Shakespeare wisely avoided a
final utterance from the undying
Falstaff how I would wince if he
departed murmuring the rest is silence
so capacious as Shakespeare's effect
upon us that we have no secular
similitudes to be offered as
alternatives the strongest of his
protagonists constitute a facticity an
entire world that contains us how can
you or I achieve perspective upon a
primordial poem of mankind that issued
incredibly from a single creative mind
we are inside shakespeare's imaginings
and therefore we scramble to see him
with any lenses not his own I no longer
go to suffer the plays staged because I
am too old to sustain yet more
exasperation at high concept directors
who assume they can think beyond him
what results are caricatures travesties
noise
I cannot delude myself that I am more
intelligent than Hamlet or Falstaff here
is the most famous soliloquy in the
language the black Prince's ontological
and meditation staled by reputation only
if you do not strive to think through it
with Hamlet let us think it through
together while forgiving my now broken
old voice and indeed it is cracked and
broken like Falstaff's ignore the
punctuation which is not shakespeare's
anyway and be aware that Hamlet's
assertions always verge upon being
questions as I say I cannot read this as
the great Sir John Gielgud could recite
it I can read it only as an interpreter
to be or not to be that is the question
whether tis nobler in the mind to suffer
the slings and arrows of outrageous
fortune or to take arms against a sea of
troubles and by opposing end them to die
to Sleep No More
and by a sleep to say we end the
heartache and the thousand natural
shocks that flesh is heir to tis a
consummation devoutly to be wish'd
to die to sleep to sleep perchance to
dream I there's the rub for in that
sleep of death what dreams may come when
we have shuffled off this mortal coil
must give us pause there's the respect
that makes calamity of so long life for
who would bear the whips and scorns of
time the oppressors wrong the proud
man's contumely the pangs of despised
love the laws delay the insolence of
office and the spurns that patient merit
of the unworthy takes when he himself
might his Quietus make with a bare
bodkin who would fardels bear grunt and
sweat under a weary life but that the
dread of something after death the
undiscovered country from whose Bourn no
traveler returns puzzles the will and
makes us rather bear those ills we have
than fly to others that we know not of
thus conscience does make cowards of us
all and thus the native hue of
resolution is sicklied o'er with the
pale cast of thought and enterprises of
great pitch and moment with this regard
their currents turn awry and lose the
name of action this absolutely is not at
all what it purports to be it is not a
reverie contemplating self-slaughter
since Hamlet greatest of ironies again
does not mean what he says or say what
he means
a psychic double-dealer he brews on the
abscess of being as his own mode of
consciousness that sea of troubles
we'll be transmuted by Milton into the
great phrase a universe of death that
the heroic Satan must explore enroute to
the new world of Eden
Hamlet Western hero of consciousness and
other conscience now invents with the
romantics what to call the power of the
poet's mind over all outward forces
soldiers of deaths cosmos Knight death
the mother and the sea Walt Whitman's
4/4 metaphor for his unknowable so so
we'll undo being an end conscience which
at once is awareness and what James
Joyce called egg and Bhairav in wit
Hamlet gives presence or being two
choices only suffer like a stoic or else
outrageously take arms against the ocean
whose heightening pitch must consume us
in its currents since our opposition
cannot hope to quell them the
consummation however devoutly desired
must conclude in consul Malta mest the
final words from the cross of being but
why does the prince so beautifully call
death the undiscovered country from
whose Bourn no traveler returns the
ghost of King Hamlet brutal and
malevolence has returned and once again
Hamlet does not mean what he says what
shall we know of whatever it is that
truly he means the puzzled will must be
the center of this fresh creation of
meaning this new birth of poetic
knowledge what is the will in
Shakespeare that overhears itself and
proceeds to well change will Shakespeare
plays on his name in the sonnets and he
wrings changes yet more profound upon it
in the tragical history of Hamlet will
in Shakespeare is desire and the
consciousness that is one of the sonnets
terrifyingly says desire is death how
can the will over here itself
the world to change conference at last
the final form of change death that
distinctly is not
the Falstaff e'en will which goes on
unsettling what passes for Shakespeare
scholars even as it exasperates their
hero the brutal and conniving Prince how
who becomes Henry v what better time to
jest and dally then in the senseless
butchery on battlefields Hamlet jests
and dollies in the graveyard but beneath
the raillery he will not say how much he
loved Yorick if only because he really
has never loved anyone else himself
included where are we to find the
meanings of Hamlet's words Falstaff is
how meaning gets started while Hamlet is
how it ends by emulating the will I do
not suggest that Shakespeare takes sides
between the two because his capacious
'no sin wounds them both you and I are
Shakespeare's objects we are the
children of his will his perspectivism
is so dumb foundering that we cannot
know whether or why we ourselves must
choose do we care where the fresh
meaning can get started in or for
ourselves I'm a bad sleep when I find
myself asking myself that four or five
times a night
Shakespeare's influence on Shakespeare
drove him to an augmenting elliptical
style of thought and rhetoric Falstaff
sister Cleopatra George Bernard Shaw
pioneered in despising them both but
fortunately no one has followed him in
that regard within sure once actually
wrote when I consider the mind of
William Shakespeare and compare it to my
own I can only feel pity for him
falstaff sister Cleopatra meets a match
not on the noble ruin of Antony but in
the clown deafs emissary who carries in
his basket the pretty worm of nilus that
kills and pains not and again my
wretched voice can't encompass this but
I need it the clown undoubtedly played
by the great later clown and for whom he
played the full in Lear and Fez D and
Twelfth Night and so on
Robert Armand look you the worm is not
to be trusted but in the keeping of wise
people for indeed there is no goodness
in the worm Cleopatra
take thou no care it shall be heated
very good give it nothing
I pray you but is not worth the feeding
and Cleopatra well it eat me I love this
well you must not think I am so simple
but I know the devil himself will not
eat a woman I know that a woman is a
dish for the gods of the devil dress or
not but truly the same Horsham devils to
the gods great harm and their women for
in every 10 that they make the devil's
Mara 5 Cleopatra well get thee gone
farewell clown
yes forsooth I wish you joy of the worm
even in Shakespeare there is nothing
else quite like Cleopatra's sudden
return to childhood fantasy I hear a
little girl enough you old serpent of
the Nile in would eat me the clown
charmed by her as we all have to be
concealed in his populist misogyny our
genuine distress and indeed his own so
magnificent a woman should slay herself
except for Falstaff and Hamlet no other
death and Shakespeare divest us of so
much life is so large withdrawal of
being tragedy and Shakespeare turns upon
a loss in being the threatens to empty
us of meaning we gain knowledge at the
expense of life and the hazards of never
some shakespeare and my experience is
the height of literary knowledge but
what is the fate of such knowledge
nothing is God for nothing the price of
love increases with aging because more
of those who loved are now among the
dead than among the living
- no fewer people without the finer tone
of knowledge which is after all human
love is a poverty that redefines
imaginative need divinity for almost all
of us no matter how we try to deceive
ourselves and others is an affair only
of silent shadow and of dreams I study
Shakespeare with great diligence hoping
to continue acquaintance with the
everliving his women and his men what is
that I know when my knowledge of them
augments or at least remains constant
Shakespeare's own invented word for the
identity of any man or woman is the self
same as all one word a deep paradox
since he is much the most metaphoric of
all writers beyond even oven
perhaps Montaigne comes closest but
Montaigne presents only the one
magnificent identity himself notoriously
Will Shakespeare has virtually no
identity whether in the summits or in
the place Hamlet has a dozen identities
and scores of modulations within him
there are more roles in him than there
are great actors to perform such immense
intricacies whatever literary knowledge
is it begins and ends with Shakespeare
except that there is no end to
Shakespeare I once believed poetic
knowledge could be regarded as
figurative thinking but now that only
seems to me one more evasion Nietzsche
defined the motive for metaphors our
desire to be different the desire to be
elsewhere but I think literary knowledge
is a larger response to desire than our
longing for a larger self seeking father
Shores
the Jesus of Mark's Gospel says he does
not know who he is and he keeps asking
his thick-headed disciples
but who do people say I am Hamlet the
secular Christ as unamuno thought Don
Quixote to be like savant a sorrowful
Knight knows exactly who he is and who
he's going to be if he chooses our sense
of who we are of what we might be as
everything to Shakespeare hist Aras is a
new descent from that but there is no
history only biography and biography
from Johnson and Boswell on is a
Shakespearean mode literary knowledge is
in the first place knowledge of
literature and after that something else
for want of another term I name this
added realm Shakespearean consciousness
that vaulting bridges the gap between
Hamlet's ever growing in witness and out
would show a pageant at once celebration
and litany we are at a festival of
knowledge since Hamlet knows more than
we know still we lament his not
divulging more and we wonder if we
resemble those poor players Rosencrantz
and Guildenstern rather than Hamlet many
of us should wince when the Prince
chives Guildenstern and again by now my
voice is completely gone I can only read
this interpretative Lea why look you now
how unworthy a thing you make of me you
will play upon me you would seem to know
my stops you would plug out the heart of
my mystery you would sell me from my
lowest note to the top of my compass and
there is much music excellent voice in
this little organ it cannot you make it
speaks obliged do you think I am easier
to be played on than a pipe call me what
instruments you will though you fret me
you cannot play upon me Hamlet like
Shakespeare composes a drama rehearsing
the mode of drama he writes I know
that's so insane his sentence I will
read it again slowly I worked it over
but I didn't find any way of putting it
more simply Hamlet like Shakespeare
composes a drama rehearsing the mode of
drama he writes
bewilderingly brilliant this propels us
into a kind of imaginal knowledge which
are simply no ground rules stage playing
is reinvented before our eyes
startling our ears as it is in those
wonderful taverns gets improvised by
Falstaff and Prince al
Lorraine knowledge perhaps can entirely
be regarded as one more play within a
play daunting al prior awareness how can
each of us cast off the shadow of self
while continuing the expansion of our
own consciousness at 81 I no longer read
to assuage loneliness early in life I
thought we read so many books because we
could not know enough people that seems
absolutely wrong now
not even Montaigne or Shakespeare
Cervantes or Proust suffice when we pine
for an absent friend or mourn the dead
without the presence of another highly
valued being the selfs shadow occludes
any heightening of awareness still we
must take our condition as given
solitude to some degree augments with
aging you begin to write as I'm now
speaking in the style of old age more
surprisingly I think the solitary reader
drifts into a new mode of reading in
which the momentous world of shakespeare
ree figures ones prior sense of spatial
relation in regard to Shakespearean
personality and characters you go from
containing Falstaff Hamlet Cleopatra to
being contained by them as though they
were the echo chamber your spirit
inhabited in the atmosphere of Solitude
the spirit with is gloriously sorrow I
associate with the stridency of
Nietzsche Zarathustra crying out but do
I bid you be either plant or phantom
Shakespearean knowledge cancels that
cloven fiction Falstaff is as much
Quicksilver spirit as sagging flesh
Hamlet the apotheosis of minds
theatricality lamented his
laid solid or solid flesh will not will
to thaw to solve itself into dawn
moisture rings Orson Welles in a letter
sublimely suggested that Hamlet sensibly
reached and then stayed in England
rejecting Elsinore slaughterhouse and
happily grew old and fat aging into Sir
John Falstaff the mercury Oh Orson
thinking his way figuratively and to
conversations with Falstaff and his
splendid film chimes at midnight gave us
the only portrait of the giant wit that
could approach Rafe Richardson's
definitive stage enactment which I saw
at 16 and hold fast by two-thirds of his
century later I returned to the ultimate
question what is Shakespearean knowledge
Giambattista Vico whose poets were Homer
Virgil and rigorously D apologized I
tripped over that hey Dante with the
theology removed grounded all-knowing
and the true poets who repopulated the
earth with giant forms by the V cone Ian
test Shakespeare is the truest poet the
knowledge Shakespeare gives us is not
language contradiction Stein but diction
the choice of words all the
Shakespearean gifts cognitive figurative
inventive of personalities depend upon
his total supremacy in diction arias
songs in the tempest are illustrative
those are pearls that were his eyes
nothing of him that doth fade but of
suffer a sea-change
into something rich and strange the
litany rings on pearls were eyes and
then on nothing fade suffer see change
to culminate magnificently with the rich
and strange that are undesignated
diction opens to the realm of the world
to change the lesson of the master
inevitability of phrasing is a nag on a
struggle in which only dante among all
western poets rivals shakespeare after
dante the italian literary language had
to be his initially highly personal
tuscan originated by Cavalcante but then
greatly surpassed in the commedia after
shakespeare english literary language
gradually unfolds into something holy
his in what ways intimate ever early
candid self reflective to hamlet
Falstaff cleopatra render us a strange
newness in meaning repetition mere
repetition consigns meaning to the
rubbish-heap
only the start of fresh meaning hurts us
enough to be memorable
what whitman fought against memory in
his leaves until hospital service among
the dead and dying broke him until then
Walt was a mythic cosmos a kind of
hermetic plural the fullness of powers
that granted a flood as the divine man
who inhabits song of myself' there is a
fullness of being in Falstaff and in
Cleopatra and a ruining of such being in
Hamlet who would wear out any cosmos
whatsoever
unlike Cleopatra and Falstaff Hamlet
gives us the illusion that he exists
neither in space nor in time yes as
though his astonished in witness
represents a reality that has priority
over every temporal and spatial division
of human existence I never quite agree
with two very gifted late friends Antony
Nadal and Francis Yates in their linkage
of Shakespeare to the hermetic fantasies
of Robert Fludd and dr. John Dee
and yet Hamlet illuminates the hermetic
image of the divine man falling outwards
and downwards into our abyss much more
fully than any esoteric tradition can
hope to clarify the Black Prince
what is foundational for the hermetic
corpus there's only another unpacking of
the heart
with words words for Hamlet so capacious
is Shakespeare's project that religious
speculations however heterodox cannot in
folder mind finally self purify the
theatrical ISM the mind of Hamlet what
then is the scope of literary knowledge
of Hamlet Falstaff Cleopatra stand at
the very center of it
Hamlet a kaleidoscope whirls his wonder
wounded heroes into a cosmological quest
absurdly too momentous for the rotten
court of Illinois Falstaff regaled with
sherry sack and doll tearsheet
challenges your perspectivism to
moralist Sir John as a cowardly buffoon
to you whoever you are you ought to be
the true image of life itself Cleopatra
to doll eyes is an age at [ __ ] to those
who can discern she personifies heroic
arrows there Shakespeare care how you
choose are not knowing that is the clue
to literary knowledge and this most
comprehensive of all knows in part only
we come to know what he knows
Hamlet defies augury and again forgive
my voice if it be tis not to come if it
be not to come it will be now if it be
not now yet it will come the readiness
is all willing to die as a shade only
from willing death Falstaff will have
none of it poor of old age though he
knows well enough that both soon we'll
have him his great enemy the Lord Chief
Justice chide Sam is not your voice
broke you'll win shirt and every part
about you blasted with antiquity to
which Falstaff who loves laughter even
more than he loves himself or Prince al
who loves laughter above all things
Falstaff greatly replies
I think sometimes this is my favorite
moment and all of fall stuff my lord
I was born about three of the o'clock on
the afternoon with a white head and
something around belly for my voice I
have lost it with hollowing and singing
of anthems crying out praises of yahwah
is hardly the Falstaff e'en mode though
in his deathbed he will sing songs I
know him better than I know Hamlet who
can identify with Hamlet all of us have
known perhaps two or three women who in
life could assume Cleopatra's garments
give me my robe but on my crown I have
immortal longings in me
would I have whatever else they may be
the triad of Falstaff Hamlet Cleopatra
are not among Shakespeare's falls of
time as so many of his protagonists have
to become it is a scholarly commonplace
that the Renaissance fiercely augmented
the classical drive to transcend time
with art outlasting eros Elizabeth's
fable chastity manipulated ins political
power became an image of temporal
constancy always the same the great
Queen resisted only the final form of
change death literary knowledge however
is of and in time and cannot exist
without consciousness of temporality of
it is the first instance of overt
literary knowledge that I can recognize
and Christopher Marlowe more than
Shakespeare seems closer to Ovid an
obsessive anxiety that forces a
specifically literary knowledge The
Tempest which in my own reading is a
final overcoming of kit Marlowe
deliberately dwarfing his dr. Faustus is
the farthest experience of literary
knowledge available to us
literary knowing is an event we're in
our own acquaintance with the known is
self reflexive and that the allusion
glares back at us when endlessly I
reread and teach it once more the
tragedy of King Lear the knowledge I
gained primarily is worth only the
uncanny fall knows on that great stage
of Falls
we cry the cry of the human as though we
are the newborn but we fall in times
theater and not into Hamlet's or
Falstaff's
theater of mind Lear's for half a
changeling child half wise beyond wisdom
knows that he and all the others on that
stage will have it with the ancient
Gnostics regarded as a cosmological
abyss and during beyond a false creation
ruined by us capricious rushing and to
being falling into time we abandon a
better knowledge for empirical caprices
if that is the best we can achieve
unless the richest node of literary
knowledge can be attained Proust much
the most Shakespearean writer of his own
time recovered knowledge in the
privileged moment that partly redeemed
time Samuel Beckett meditating on proofs
from a Joycean perspective reminds us of
the link through John Ruskin to the high
romantic spots of time secularized
epiphanies the world's revenge against
time and times it was a failed
Nietzschean quest brilliantly is
isolated by Proust as sexual jealousy
restored to the Shakespearean intensity
of Othello and of Laertes in The
Winter's Tale the pristine comedy of
sexual jealousy plays against
Shakespeare's dark a view of it but both
augmenta understanding of literary
knowledge and proofs the jealous lover
is an art historian searching for every
visual and temporal evidence of
infidelity as fool's of time we are all
of us agonize lovers fantasizing
fictions of duration that if they are
jealous enough become our own bad poems
or stories if I had to choose one
character only as a guide to literary
knowledge would of course be Sir John
Falstaff rather than Hamlet or Cleopatra
Dante the pilgrim or Don Quixote Proust
narrator or Leopold Bloom for me the
question what is literary knowledge is
answered by Falstaff why he need not
quest for lost time since he
triumphantly has thrust time aside and
Bennett pass he is not human all too
human
as academic moralist tiresomely repeat
to me he is the true and perfect image
of life itself turn him and turn him for
everything is in him thank you